では よろしくお願いします
今日はダンマパダの八十九番目と八十六番目まで続けてやると思います
アッペカーテマヌッセス
イエジャナ・パーラガミノ
アターヤン・イタラ・パジャー・ティーラメヴァヌ・ダーヴァティ
イエチャ・コー・サッマ・ダッカテ
ダンメ・ダンマ・アヌヴァッティーノ
テージャナー・パーラメッサンティ
マッチュデイヤン・スドゥッタラン・ティ
で そういう偈で もう一度発音を見てください
アッペカーテ・マヌッセス
イエジャナ・パーラガミノ
アターヤン・イタラ・パジャー・ティーラメヴァヌ・ダーヴァティ
イエチャ・コー・サッマ・ダッカテ
ダンメ・ダンマ・アヌヴァッティーノ
テージャナー・パーラメッサンティ
マッチュデイヤン・スドゥッタラン・ティ
アッペカーテ・マヌッセスっていうのはアッペカーっていうのは数少ないんだと
テー・マヌッセス この人間の中で
イエジャナ・パーラガミノ
乗り越える  パーラガミっていうのは
この岸からあの岸へ渡るということで
この場合は死ぬことではなくて
涅槃に達すること 輪廻を乗り越えるということですね
解脱することです だからパーラガミ
出世間の境地に達する人々はとても少ないんだと
人々の中で アターヤン・イタラ・パジャ
他のもう多数の人々が
ティーラメヴァヌ・ダーヴァティ
この岸で走っているだけですと
あちらまでは乗り越えていかないんですということ
次の偈はイエチャ・コー・サッマ・ダッカテ
サッマ・ダッカテっていうのはよく説かれていることですね
ダンメ 真理はとても見事に正しく
しっかりと説かれているんです
微塵も間違わないように
その真理に対してダンマ・アヌヴァッティーの真理に従って行を行う
実践をしてみる もし誰かが正しく説かれているこの真理に従って生活するならば
テージャナー・パーラメッサンティ
そういう人々ならあの世に行きますよと
出世間の境地に達しますよと
マッチュデイヤン・スドゥッタラン
マッチュデイヤというのはこの
死の王国という意味なんですけど
死の縄張り 王国 そこはスドゥッタラン
そう簡単に乗り越えられないんだよと
乗り越えがたい 乗り越えがたい死の国を脱出するんだということ
誰が脱出するのかというと
この正しく説かれた真理に従う人ですね
だから 他の人には無理ということ
いくら頑張っても いくら頑張っても
できるわけじゃないんです
そういうことで まあそれほど表面的には難しい意味ではないんです
お釈迦様の時代でお釈迦様の観察から見ても
解脱に成功する人々の方がとても少ないということになるんです
お釈迦様に時々挑戦されたことがありますけど
あの あなたの教えはね
何かすごい理解できそうでもなく
とても難しそうなものでね
でも言ってることは何かあまりにも素晴らしくてね
まあそういうことはね
あなた以外誰一人でも達しているならばすごいことでしょうと言われたら
それっていうのは この聞いた人がそこをまあ解脱というのはいくら考えたってもね
論理的には不可能という立場なんですね
だったら一人でも達しているならばすごいことだと
お釈迦様は一人だと思いますかと
一人じゃなくて  10人で言っても
20人で言っても  30人
100人  80人単義で言っても
もう出家比丘たちがいるんだよと
何 100人単義ではなくちゃいけない
じゃあ比丘尼たちにしたっても
一人一人 10人単義ではなくて
100人単義でいたら何 100人もいますよと
在家の男性も女性もいくらでもいますよということは言うんですよ
だから確かに お釈迦様の時代ではたくさん悟りに達していたことがいたんです
しかし だから結構すごいということではないんですよ
人類から見てみると まあ比較にならないですよ
あの現代インド人にインドには仏教ありませんと言ったら結構腹が立つんですよ
ただ自慢だけで 実際は 1割もいないんです
それも仏教でしょうかと言えばそうじゃなくて
アンベッドカールさんのグループなんですね
だから仏教を信仰しているかどうかちょっとわかりにくいんですけど
ただ アンベッドカールさんを信仰して
我々は仏教徒やと言って
ヒンドゥー教から離れているぐらいのことなんですね
それでも仏教ですから
仏教徒と名乗っているんですからね
そこのグループだって 1割も満たさないぐらい少ないんですよ
それは現代の状況と これと関係ないんだけど
あの仏教徒もたくさんいるかもしれませんだけど
解脱に達する人っていうのはすごい少ない
珍しいっていうことが
まあお釈迦様の時代で見ても同じことになるんです
他の人々はまあ頑張っているんだけど
なかなかこちらでぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回っているだけよと
じゃあ ティーラメーワヌダーワティ
一応進んではいくんだけど
岸のところに行ったらまたもっと戻ってくる
またまたじゃあ行こうかなと言って
向こうには行かないんで
こちらで止まっちゃおうっていうね
高跳びする時はね よく走って
棒も持ってきて サーッと走って
跳ぶところへ来て また止まる
止まったらもう終わりですからね
やっぱり高いと そんなことしたって飛ばなくちゃ
ああそうですかと また元に戻って
まだずーっと走ってきて
またカチッとそちら棒をさせて止まるというね
いうふうなことですね
こちらで言っているのは
では誰が飛べるかと 乗り越えられるかというと
やっぱりこのサンマダッカータっていうのは正しく説かれたというね
その言葉にポイントがあるんですよ
日本訳ではね 真理が正しく説かれた時にっていう風にありますが
それよりは意味は文法的に分析すると
正しく説かれた真理っていうことになります
時にということは訳できないわけではありません
お釈迦様が言わんとする意味っていうのは
確実に普通文法書を開けて見ただけでは取れない可能性はいくらでもあります
微妙に変えなくちゃいけないという
ですから この場合は正しく説かれた真理でよろしいと思いますね
だからアッカータンという各分子にアッカーテという風に各変化すればロキチュエースでね
サンマダッカーテ 正しく説かれた真理に合うように実践しなくちゃいけないんですね
なぜ正しくとか 例えて言うと
ここがキーワードですかね
これすぐもうもうもう聞き逃しちゃうところって
見逃しちゃうところなんですよ
お釈迦様はその言葉を強調するんです
だから普通はよくよく喋ってるんだよと言ったら
なんか宣伝だと思うんですよ
摩訶不思議に見事に語られているんだというと
いわゆる宣伝文句に感じちゃうんですね
これ宣伝文句じゃないんですね
そこは結構もう我々は見逃しちゃうところなんです
ブッダが見事に教えているんだというね
お釈迦様の言語の使い方達者とかね
表現力が達者とかね そういう宣伝文句じゃありません
それを覚えておいてください
で 法に礼拝する時でも
まず始めるのはスワッカータ
バカヴァダッダーム スワッカータというのは正しく説かれているんだと
これが大事な単語なんです
宣伝ではありません ブッダの言葉っていうのは
どんな角度から見ても完全に説かれているんですよ
それだけでも奇跡なんです
不可能ですよ 言葉で完全に表現するっていうことは
これありえないんです
言語っていうのはみんな使ってますけど
言語という道具の達人たちが文学作家なんですね
文学作品とか小説とか何だらかんだらっていうのは
ただ言語の演奏家なんですね
言語そのものを見事に演奏する
それってみんなにある能力でもないんですが
言語好きな人はガチャガチャガチャガチャと言語学べば演奏する能力は身につく可能性はあります
それで 例えば詩人が何かテーマを歌うと
けれど それが最高な歌でしょうか？と
他の人に同じテーマで歌を書けないのかと
書けますよ で これがこれ以上立派なものは誰も作れませんということはちょっとありえないんです
だから私が言いたいポイントは
たとえ言語を上手に演奏できるね
作家の人であっても 見事に言うことはできません
それなりにすごい立派な言葉ですよとは言えますけどね
で そこは人類の中で 私はお釈迦様だけやと思いますね
見事に語ったっていうね
で それは確かにありますけどね
ブッダの言葉にはもうどう頑張ってもケチつけることできないんです
他はどんな立派な言葉であっても
いっぱい世の中で立派な言葉っていうのはいくらでもありますけど
何かちょこっと何かからかってやることはできます
ブッダの言葉には これどうも結構厳しい
無理ですね しかし このポイントはそれ言ってるわけじゃないんです
正しく説かれたっていうとこは
この言語から見れば見事完璧やという意味じゃないんです
どちらかと言えば お釈迦様の言葉っていうのはそんなに気にしてないんです
お話の時はもう単語なんかダラダラダラ使ったりするんです
もう似てる言葉があるならば全部使ったりしててね
繰り返しまでしたりして
そんなに言語に対してはそんなに真剣に考えてないんですね
なのにかなり大雑把で言葉使ってますけど
すごい見事に解くんですね
そこで意味は何ですかね
この正しく説かれたということは
お釈迦様は悟りに達する法を説いてる
教えてるんですよ それを完璧に説いてるんです
これが解脱に達する道であると
そこは誰にも訂正できないんです
だから このブッダの教えにそのままぴったしと従って実践しなくちゃいけないんです
誰も好き勝手に自分の考えでもうあれこれと改良するっていうことは
これはもう不可能 ですが
それみんなやってるんですね
世の中を見ると 仏教の世界を見ると
みんな自分のシステムを作るんですね
瞑想の人ってごちゃごちゃ無茶苦茶なんですね
いろんな方法を自分で考えたり導入したりして
あのところで言っていることと我々は違いますよとかね
言うことが絶対やってはいけないことなんです
で なんで悟らないのかという
そちらにポイントあるんですよ
修行は自分で改良するわけです
それだけ絶対やってはいけないことなんです
で みんな仏法僧を信仰しながら
仏教でありながら そこを絶対やってはいけないことを平気でやるんです
誰も悟りに達しないんです
微妙に間違ったらもう終わり
もうさようなら 道が違う
飛べないんです それで修行っていうのはもう表面的には簡単ですが
これ表面的に簡単ということがもう見事に説かれているところなんです
不可能とは誰にも思わせません
なのに やっている過程で
次々他の方法がないのかとか探したりする
そこでもう改悪させているところあったらならば飛んでそちらに行くんです
どうしても仏道を改良する人々は
一般人の人気を人を呼び寄せるためにやっているんだからね
だから俗人にまく餌だからね
得なものじゃないんです
それにそれ食っていくんだから
やっぱり道が間違っちゃうんですね
仏道では餌撒きません
人気を作るために 人を呼び寄せるために
人にアピールするために何もしません
で 一般的な社会では これでは困りますよと
やっぱり一般人にアピールするようになんとか何とかしなくちゃっていうことで何とかする
そこはやってはいけないことなんです
仏道は正しい 正しく説かれています
そういうことで これはとっても大変な単語なんです
だから三宝に来拝する時でも
法になると 1番目の頭に来る言葉がスワカータ
法に対していう場合は
いつでも先に来るのはスワカータ
それは言語上手っていう意味じゃないんです
表現力がすごいっていうことでは全くありません
そういう特色は当然あります
ブッダの言葉に攻撃できる人はいません
我々はすごいすごい見事だというセクションじゃない
それは俗世間の目で見てね
いろんな哲学者の言葉やら
いろんな世の中に生き残っていることわざやらね
金言やら そういうものと比較すると
もうブッダの言葉っていうのはもう敵わない
すごい それに似るように言葉さえも言えない
それはそれじゃありません
こちらで言っているスワカータは
サマーって違うんですか？ ん？ スワカータ
何？ ごめんなさい すいません
で ですから この正しく説かれているスワカータ
こちらではサッマダッカータ
これサッマ入るとダーが入りますけどね
あれなんで入るのかわかりませんだけど
サッマ サッマッカータとは言わないんですね
かっこ悪いんですね サッマッ
サッミャク サッミャクというね
sanskrit サッミャクですからね
で 慧は堕するんですね
濁っちゃうんです sammā
rakkhati 正しく説かれている
で あの この方法論 やり方っていうことはね
どんなやり方でもいいっていうことじゃありません
しっかりした達するべき目的があるならば
しっかりした出すべき答えがあるならば
もう何やってもいいわけにはならないんです
やっぱり俗世間見ても
どんなものにもやり方っていうものっていうのは一応成り立ちますよ
そのやり方でやれば決まってる結果が出てきます
やり方は少々変えると結果が違いますね
簡単な例で おかゆを作ると
やり方があるんですよ
米といて水を入れて火にかけるだけやと
じゃないんです 例えば炊飯器でそこ立っても
お米の量と水の量っていう決まりがあるんですね
それ変わるとどうなるんですかね
おかゆじゃなくてご飯になってしまうとかね
あるいは水の量がもっと減ると
ご飯でもなくなっちゃって半熟になっちゃうんですね
じゃあ米 米ちょっと先に炒ってみましょうと
米を先に乾煎りする それからちゃんとおかゆを作ると
やっぱり結果が違います
米を乾煎りしておかゆ作る方法もあります
冗談で言ったわけじゃないんです
で やっぱりそれは別のおかゆなんですね
アーユルヴェーダ世界ではね
おかゆも一つの治療方法だから
だから病気に合わせて普通のお米でおかゆを飲みなさい
食べなさいという場合も
米をまず炒って それからおかゆ作りなさいという両方あります
[笑い]それなりに効能が違います
だからこの言う通りにやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
おかゆ食べなさいと言った人
おかゆ ついでにおいしいんだから鶏肉も入れましょうよと
ついでにおいしいんだからね
もうまた何か何か入れましょうよとかね
すると結果が違います
もし消化不良で腸が動かない人で
もうなんとかもうエネルギーだけ与えたいだけの時はね
胃に負担かけないで で
点滴は危ないんですからね
やっぱり胃を通して体に入った方が胃を休めてはいけませんし
だから胃がもう弱いんだから仕事をさせてもいけません
だから ちょっと微妙な仕事をさせるために
まあおかゆ食べさせることで
そこで美味しいんだから
もうやっぱり鶏肉も入れましょうと
まあついでに鶏肉入れたもんだから
じゃあまあ何て言いますか
人参も色も綺麗だしね
やっぱり人参黄色いだから何か緑色の方もあった方がいいと
また何か入れたりすると結果が違います
それでお腹が壊れている人はなおさら壊れて死んでしまうという
消化できなくて 美味しさに文句言ったって意味がないんです
あんたおかゆを食べなさいと言ったところ
おかゆ食べてみたんですけど
それでこの人はなおさらひどい目に遭ってね
もう重体になりましたと言ったっても
もう知らんということになるんです
そういうわけで 単純におかゆの作り方であっても
作り方があって そこはもう変えてはいけません
塩少々と言っても 塩2キロの袋を見たら
そちらの塩をもう一握り取ったっても少々だからね
もう手でもう一つ握って
じゃあこの見たら少々でしょう
はい どーんと それで結果が違いますからね
そういう悟りに達する方法については
微妙にも変えることできないこの方法を説いたんです
そこはなぜ重体かで 心っていうのはものすごい管理しがたい
大変なものなんですね
もう何だか瞑想したんだからうまくいくっていうことはね
もう心というのは それがとてもわかりにくい働きをするんですね
で わかりにくい働きは仏教で説明していますけど
とにかく幻覚を作るだけのことなんです
それは仏教以外誰もわかってないし
心は自分で結果を考えてそこを作り出すんですね
その作った結果が本物じゃなくて幻覚なんです
普通心がそういう働きなんですよ
だからいつでも結果に達しているつもりになっちゃうんです
お化粧することと同じことなんですよ
心が美人でいたいと決めちゃうんですよ
そこで何とかするんです
何か塗ったりとかね はい
美人になったと 美人になったつもりになるんです
我々はそういうこのつもりの世界でいるんですよ
服を選ぶ時でも もうかっこよくなった気分でいるんです
だから人が批判していても
本人が間違いなくかっこいいんだと
私は気に入っているんだよと
だから心はそれで満足しているんです
客観的な結果は気にしません
心にはそういう働きがありまして
何か希望を作る それからその希望に達した気分になる
希望に達した気分になって
まぁ我輩は良かったと
と満足するという しかしながら幻覚だから
本物じゃないんだから
つもりだけのことだから
もうエネルギーはないんですよ
だから 何か次何かやらなくちゃいけないんですね
例えばもう最高のご馳走を食べるつもりで茶漬けを食べると
随分おしゃれをして 手すくとこうかっこよく作って
結構かっこいい豪華な食器に食器を持ってきて
もうもう花も生けてもらって
音楽もBGMも流して
お茶漬けを食べると ご馳走食べたと
で 気分になる 気分になったんで
実際食べたのはお茶漬けだから
ご馳走じゃないんですよ
だからご馳走を食べたその実際のエネルギー
結果が生まれるわけじゃないんです
気分だけ だからちょっと時間経つと
また何かやらなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると次のことをやりますけど
同じことですね またつもりで喜んじゃうんです
そういうことで 我々はつもりの世界で生きているんですね
幸福になったつもり 幸せになったつもり
成功したつもり 最悪の場合
悟ったつもりにもなります
ですから この戦時下であるブッダが悟ったブッダが言う方法には
もう微妙にでも触れてはならん
そのまま実践するしかないんです
だから仏道を微塵も変えるなよと
触るなよと そのままの形でやりなさいということなんです
サッマダッカって そこで結構大変な単語なんです
わずかな変化もダメなんです
線路で例えてみれば 線路はいろいろ繋げてますよ
で 最初はもう 三センチぐらいのズレですかね
三センチじゃないんです
大体五ミリ もうないんですね
線路をつなげるところの
微妙な差なんです まあ三ミリぐらいどうったことないんだと
だってプレートいうね
車両には受け来る幅が置いて開くんだからね
その幅なんですよ その幅で次の線路にはめるんです
だったら別なところに行くんです
行く道でちょっと三ミリずれたってどうったことないんだと
線路で考えれば三ミリずれたら別なところに行くんです
行くところじゃない 行きたかったところじゃないんです
だから仏道で微妙にでも変えたら自分が変えたんだからね
自分の心で つもり心で
そこで難しいところは
ずっとつもりの世界で生きている人にとっては
どんな方法であっても
つもりの方だったら分かりやすいんです
すぐ人気が出ます だから日本でね
かなりこの浄土教が広げた時は
かなり一般人の間でザーッと
つもりの世界だからね
極楽道に行けると 往生できるというつもりで
神を信仰する宗教はなんで人気あるのかというと
当たり前 あれはつもりの世界の代表ですね
すべてつもりのつもり
洗礼を受けたら罪が全部なくなったつもり
悔い改めますと それで洗礼を受ける
完璧 ということになるんですね
だから一番分かりやすいのはその洗礼の習慣ですね
洗礼していない人々は
一般キリスト教では天国に行けないんですね
カトリック教では単語を使ってまして
貧乏という LIMBO
貧乏じゃないんだ 貧乏の我々のことです LIMBO
英語で貧乏っていうのは別な意味なんで
英語の単語あります 貧乏という
だらしない女って意味なんです
散らかして もうそういうちょっと品のない迷惑
で 女性に対して使う単語は貧乏ですけど LIMBO
よくああいう単語作るんだなと思いますけどね
つもりの世界で作るんですね
どう見たっても洗礼を受けて
特にそのLIMBO状態に行くのは
もう洗礼を受ける前に亡くなる子供たちは地獄に落とすことも不可能でしょうし
だからただ洗礼を受ける前に亡くなっただけだからね
天国はダメでしょうと
もう洗礼を受けて罪を全部
人間に生まれたら罪人だから
罪人で生まれたんですけど
洗礼を受けてないんだから
地獄に落としても悪いし
だから平気で勝手にLIMBOという単語を使って
そういうどうにもならんところに行くんだと
だからそういうとても一番智慧のない
論理性ない世界の人々の考え方からは心の問題は見えてきます
ちょっと論理が入ってくると面倒くさいんだからね
論理ないんだからね だから水をかけただけで全部罪が消えますと
原罪は消えますと それから神を信じるだけ
それでつもりの世界ですね
だから一般の人はそれなら分かりやすい
やりたくもなる それぐらいのことで自分の罪がなくなるんですかね
だったらもう飛んでやりますということで
もう飛び上がってやりたくなっちゃう
で 心を持ってる生命には誰にでもその問題があるんです
これ人間に限らず 生命はいろんな次元を持っているのは心の問題だから
物質的なことじゃないんです
だから餓鬼にもなるし
天国にも行くし 地獄にも落ちるし
畜生にもなるし いろんなところで心は変化していきますからね
だから心があるっていうことは生命であって
心がやっぱり幻覚者で
自分で作って 自分でその幻覚を作って
それから自分で期待をして幻覚を作ってなったつもりになる
でももうなんかどうも困ると
ではまた新しい希望を作って
それに挑戦して またなったつもりでいて
またちょっと違うと 次の希望を作って
それになったつもりで
それで無限で続くんです
その方法しか心は知らないんですね
このつもりの輪からは脱出する方法を知らないんですね
だから真理は ことわざで言えば花より団子なんです
それは世間ではなんか悪いことわざにしているでしょうに
ほら 美しく花が咲いているのに
この美しさを喜ばないで
このバカが食い物に手を出して
とんでもないやつやという意味なんです
まあわかりやすく言えば
まあ愚か者やと その意味を表現するためにあることわざが花より団子
残念ながらそれが事実なんです
バカじゃなくて その人こそが賢いんです
みんなと花見に行くんですけど
花はどうでもいいんですけど
食べるんです 置いてる
ああ 気持ちよかったと
確かに気持ちよかったんです
花見を見て もうキャーキャーと騒いだりして
もう気持ちよくて何も気持ちよくてないんです
疲れているんです で 心は賢いやと思ってね
花より団子はや間違いやと生き方しているんです
そういうややこしいところがあるんだから
お釈迦様はしっかりとスワカータ
あるいはサッマダッカータ
ちゃんと教えているんだと
正しく その通りにそのままやってくださいと
人にそれを改良する自由っていうのは全くもないんです
資格はないんです 悟りに達してないんだから
歩んだことはない世界だから
ガイドブック作るんじゃないんです
ガイドブック作るのはその道を歩んだ人なんです
一度も外国に行ったことない人が
一度も入国管理局を通ったことがない人が
もう地球の歩き方とかね
空港のいろいろの手続きのこと書けるわけないでしょうに
しかし ものの見事に自分が歩んだこともない
経験したこともない世界について
自分でガイドブックを書くんです
書いてやってみるんです
そうするとつもりになるんです
子供頃は 子供はよく子供はつもり遊びよくやっているでしょう
いろんなね 例えばこの
いろんな怪獣の話やらいっぱい
いろんなもの フィギュア持ってきてね
百円二百円でそれ買って
で 漫画にあるいろんなキャラクターをね
大量に売ってますからね
おもちゃ屋さんで あれは子供たちのもう明確なつもりの遊びなんですね
だからつもり病は子供の心を見るとちゃんと見えます
そういうことでサッマダッカータっていうのは
この心に本来あるこのつもり病で感染したら困ります
悟れません だから悟る人が少ないんだよと
少ないんだよと言って
それで話は終わりませんよ
不平不満だけ言って終わりません
理由まで言うんです 理由はこういう理由であると
乗り越えがたいんだよと
この輪廻は そこでこの岸側のこちらでうろうろうろうろしているんだっていうところは
注釈書ではこのウシンケンサッカーヤ
この実体論 私がいるんだというね
そこは破れないんだと
そこはティーラメーワヌダーワティという単語でそこを説明しているんだと
そこで注釈書でも 仏道は微塵も改良不可能であるものであるというところは何も言わないんですね
だからそのポイントは何のことなく見逃しちゃうんです
注釈書やらね 仏教をやってる
いわゆる上座部仏教の長老たちっていうのは
もう決まり ブッダの言葉はもう金言で
もう絶対的で もうそれは絶対的な言葉で
もう変えることはできないということは
基本的に決まってますからね
それは全体的なことでね
戒律から何でもかんでも最終決断はブッダの言葉になると
お坊さんたちの間でいろんなものについて異論が出てくると
もういっぱい喋って喋って喋って
なかなか結論ができない場合は
まあじゃあ最終決断 答えはどうなるのかというと
ブッダの言葉でそのことを調べてみて
何か言葉があったらそれで終わり
結論ということになるんです
しかし ブッダの言葉を解説するために
何か異論が成り立っちゃうと
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
だから問題を起こるのはブッダの言葉を解説しようとする時なんです
その時は自分で解説しちゃうんですね
やがて自分の意見はブッダの意見にするんですね
この間 こちらにある誰かの中国系の人が書いたテーラワーダの
テーラワーダ的な本ですけどね
まあ英語の本だったらちょっと読んでくださいとある人に言いましたから
その人は一冊読んでみて
一部問題があるんだと
輪廻に対して ヨーロッパ人だからやっぱり輪廻っていうのは理解できないんだから
そこはちょっと疑問に思うんですね
私はその人で 「あなたには理解できない
しかし それが否定する理由になりませんよ」と 「
よく覚えておいてください」と 「
私にはわかりません だから真実ではありません」という論になりますからね
それを間違って 「それはわかってますよ
じゃあ気をつけろ」と
あなたにわからなくても
それは勉強する衝動になるだけであって
それで論点を否定するためには証拠になりませんよと
みんなよくそれやってますよと
あなた方ヨーロッパ人も等々と
俺にはわからない したがって嘘である
それで その本でも輪廻のところになったところで
それはどうせ英語で書くんだからね
英語を喋る人々のことを頭の中でイメージして書くんだからね
輪廻っていうのはこの世の中でね
心の変換だと 時々畜生のような心になったり
時々天のような心になったり
時々地獄に落ちて落ちてるような気持ちになったりするという
あらゆる変化が起こるんだと
その人の人格は変わるでしょうと
それがもう限りなく続くでしょうと
だって心の変換がずっと死ぬまで続くんだからね
止まらないんだからね
それが輪廻であると 見事に
輪廻転生はもう否定するんじゃなくて
カットするんですね そこを本を真面目に読んだ人が
生命はこの命だけに限るという証拠も何もない
結論に出してしまうんですね
だから その場合も やっぱり本人がお釈迦様は堂々と輪廻のことを言っているのに
だから じゃあ輪廻をどう説明する？自分知っている世界で説明しようとするんですね
そこで説明したつもりになるんです
それで輪廻をわかったつもりになるんです
輪廻はそんなことでわかりません
それはもう超越した智慧がないと
過去を見る 過去を自分で目の前で経験するより能力あった人にだけ実証する現象なんですよ
どう見たってもその通りですよね
自分が死んでから死後あるということは
過去があるということだから
将来はないんだから見られないし
ですから過去を見るんです
過去があったならば 将来もあるのは当たり前やというふうに推測するんです
私には過去があったんだと
その過去 以前もまた過去があったと
以前の過去がそこで現在になって
そこはなくなって また新しい自分が現れてきて
そうやって過去がたどってみると過去があるんだと
現在で終わりですからということにすればダメですからね
そういう結論は ということは
死んだらまた現れるということは過去で経験したんだと
だから将来もあると 仏教の問題は
なぜそうなったのかという原因
過去で死んで過去で生まれた人が
その時の心の状況が何かあったんだから生まれたでしょうに
じゃあその原因は取り除いたのかと
取り除いてないんですね
今の心でも 特別に何かやってないんだから
ただ生きているだけのことだから
過去も生きていただけだからね
生きてただけで だって生まれちゃったと
また それだったら今も生きているだけだから
また生まれちゃうと それで修行っていうのは
そのまた生まれを司る
司る原因を取り除くということなんです
転生を司る原因を取り除いたら
転生がないってことになるんですね
で そのポイントはそうなんですが
自分の理屈で理解をするとつもりの世界になるんですね
だから当然みんなにその経験がありますから
時々天国の気分でいたりして
で ほとんど地獄に陥れた気分でほとんど一日生きていて
たまにもう百年一回ぐらい天国に行ったような気分になったりとかだけだから
そこでのもう気持ちは本物だからね
結局は それが転生であると
理解できそうで あれはつもりなんですね
本人はつもりにつもりだと思わないんです
理解できた よく説明できたと
そこでこの本格の人間の間違いは
輪廻はそういうものであると書く文章なんです
私は自分の我が儘で勝手で
こういうふうに解説するんだと言った方が正しい
それはお釈迦様 言葉正しくはないんだけど
お釈迦様は真理を語る
真理を守るって二つ分けてます
真理を知らなくても もう壊さない
守る 真理守る人は 私は自分の勝手で
自分の理解能力範囲でこのように分析しましたと
その場合は事実は知らんぞと
そういう意味ですからね
その一言も入れないんですね
私は文章を作る場合は
ですと思いますっていうとすごい微妙に区別しています
ほとんどの私の文章は日本語の普通の日本語と違ってね
全部ちゃんとです なりますで終わるんです
が でしょうで終わる時もあります
と思いますで終わる文章もあります
結構違います 皆様はサッと読んでしまうかもしれませんだけど
[背景の音楽]いくら早く読み合わせしたっても
ずっとそこら辺は動詞は気をつけるんです
そういうことで このあの偈二つのポイントはsammā-diṭṭhīという言葉なんです
で 積もりの世界に対するブッダの注意ですね
仏教以外何も知らない人であっても
気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
訂正するつもりになるんです
道を 輪廻を脱出するって解脱に達するっていうことは
まあ結構大変です 木曜日で
朝会チャーの授業で 一応サティに達するために必要なエネルギーについてちょっと紹介はしました
初めて で 結構かなりのエネルギーが必要になります
うん いろいろ工夫して
この輪廻脱出するためのエネルギーをね
たくわえてなくちゃいけないんですね
だから エネルギー溜まること自体っていうのは
人間にとってはすごいストレスであると
しかし 悪い悪ストレスをやめて善のストレスもありますと
どうしても避けられませんよ
ディストレスからは エネルギーは必要です
今悪のエネルギーで生きているんだからね
そこはもう変えて善というエネルギーに入れ替えなくちゃいけない
そこはもう悪のエネルギーはあまりたくさんのはたまりません
すぐもう破壊されます
善のエネルギーはかなり大量には溜まります
これでまた逆に極限に溜まったところで脱出するんです
だから高跳びする例えと同じなんですよ
走ってきてエネルギーを溜めて
カチッと止めて棒を刺すところで全力から絞らなくちゃいけないんです
自分持ってる力というのは一切その瞬間に絞ったところで跳べるんです
その時集中力もね 微塵でもどうかなという微塵
思考入っちゃうと飛ばないんですよ
単純にもう高飛びだけの話ですけどね
その時でも身体力だけではなくて
精神力も全部一つその瞬間に来ないと
だからそういう瞬間でも人には妄想はないんです
その飛ぶ瞬間に 本人も何が起きたかわからないと
それででは終わります
マッチュ デーヤン スドゥッタランね
悪魔の死の領域をそう簡単に飛べないんだよと
いうことで すごいエネルギーが必要だよっていうこともあります
[背景音]